[Music]
hello youtube just Louis my friends this
is grunge in here welcome to the ninth
episode of dirty ch Asterix again
Sicilian now as per the many requests in
this episode I'm going to show you some
of the wonderful tricks in the Smith
Morra gambit accepted main line from the
white perspective the opening arises
after the following model that is e for
C Phi D for C captures D for and now
wide gambit the pawn for a very fast
development that is c3 black accept the
challenge that is D capture c3 and night
capture c3 after Knight to c6 Knight to
f3 d6 and Bishop to c4 we reach to the
starting position of the main line of
the Mora gambit accepted
now here the main movies ecigs but as
happened in many opening if black
doesn't aware of the scenario then he
can likely to make this blunder that is
Knight to f6 which in fact when I
checked this position in online database
I found out that this has been tried
even in the recent years so it is very
important for you to know why this is
considered as a big time mistake well
here the obvious response is ePHI so
attacking two sports and the famous
blunder here is Knight captures ePHI
which leads to the instant disaster
after Knight captures e5 pawn captures
ePHI and now Bishop to f7 and black
loses the whole Queen
so that captures Aoife is completely out
of the equation so black has to accept
with the D pawn but after that white is
going to exchange the Queen and now
black has two responses and neither of
them are good for the black the obvious
move King captures d8 has a bad
reputation because of the move Knight to
g5 and now white is indeed threatening
the epsilon and there is no way black
and stop it if King to c7 then Knight
captures f7 is a very strong reply so
the most critical reply by the black
over here is Knight to e5 attacking the
bishop and what black is hoping is maybe
black and get two pcs for a rook and
managed to get a playable position well
of course here we are not going to play
Knight to f7 but instead of that my
recommendation is you should play Bishop
captures f7 and after the following
sequence that is e six Bishop captures a
six Bishop captures a six Knight
captures c6 track King to d7 and now the
simplest move Knight captures f8 rook
captures f8 and castle on the Kings side
after the whole sequence it turns out
that White has at least one Bishop and
black has the open King and have
clear-cut target on e5 which is not easy
to play
so what all I think here it is only
white who is playing for the win the
second move I want to consider is night
captures d8 in order to retain one pawn
and safeguarding the f7 square but here
I can create another sort of problem
after this move that is night to be Phi
so now it is threatening the moonlight
to c7 and foking king and rook
so black needs to stop it King to d7 can
be easily met with the move Knight
captures ePHI so the only good reply
over here is rook to b8 afterwards white
should continue with the move Knight
captures ePHI so this time around what
is threatening nothing but a simple
night mate so in order to stop that the
good reply o here is e 6 and majority of
the player has played the moonlight to
c7 which I personally think it's
inaccurate here my recommendation is you
should Castle first and now white is
also to get a winning position for
example if black routinely continue here
with Bishop to e7 then after Knight
captures a 7 castle on the King side and
the move Bishop to e3 not only White has
a superior minor piece development but
White has a majority on the Queen side
which is always a deciding factor in
such a situations so that's why what
happened if you open and try to save the
pawn with the move a 6 well now he's
going to get a bigger problem because
after Knight check King to e7 and now
Bishop to F for creating a x-ray on the
black rogue so black has to act
immediately with Knight to h5 attacking
the bishop but after Bishop to e3 I
think this is a very pleasant scenario
for the white kindly note black cannot
immediately kick the ephah Knight with
the mu abscess
because after Bishop to c5 black king is
going to be checkmated so considering
this fact
I get this position in one game against
a 1988 player where my opponent
continued with the move Knight to c6
which in this situation is the best
reply but after the following sequence
of the moves that is f4 Knight to f6
Bishop to c5 check came to d8 Bishop to
b6 trying to get a discover attack so my
opponent has to forcefully play the move
King to e7
but after rook a to d1 I think his
species are completely boxed in
he tried Bishop to d7 but then the
tactics was waiting for him as after the
move Bishop captures c6 BAM black is
completely busted
he tried F captures e6 but after Bishop
check King to d8 and Knight captures a 6
during the whole game was enjoyed
attacking and at the end after all the
fireworks white emerged within pawn
advantage and a winning position
so it is very clear that Knight to f6 is
a big-time mistake at this position so
black should continue with the movie six
which is in fact the male line of the
Mora gambit accepted here
why should castle on the Kings side and
now in the majority of the cases black
has tried the knight moves but I think
the a6 is a more accurate choice over
here because Knight moves allow white to
execute his dirty chess tricks the first
more I want to consider is Knight and G
to e7 well here the obvious response is
Bishop to g5 which create one of the
amazing trick in the Mora gambit as
black has to play accurate move a6 in
this position but he play moves such as
at six
which in fact happen at some
high-profile games but it is outright
mistake as white get the winning
position in the opening with the next
move that is Knight to B Phi and there
is no way black and save the d6 pawn if
black greedily take this bishop then
after Knight catches d6 check King to d7
and Knight captures b7 black is going to
lose a queen and if we try to save this
with the move D Phi which is the course
of my blitz game against a 1800 rated
opponent but I am afraid this is not
going to solve any problems as after the
following continuation that is e
captures D Phi pawn captures G Phi D
captures c6 kindly note black is in the
no position to exchange the Queen
because of the move Knight to c7 check
so my opponent try the move Bishop
captures c6 but after Bishop captures a
six pawn captures a six and the Moon
Knight to d6 we get the familiar pattern
where black loses the Queen and in fact
the game
the second night move I want to consider
is Knight to f6 which is the most
popular choice at this position well
after that white will continue with his
normal piece development such as Queen
to e2 Bishop to e7 and now rook to d1
once again we reach to the very critical
position where black has to play some
accurate moves and here black has to
play move such as either Aoife and
Bishop to d7 afterwards the game is
completely balanced but the many times
what happens is people play moves such
as a6 and the most natural move in this
position is schedule which is the
outright mistake but surprisingly enough
I have seen this move tried recently and
to illustrate my point I like to draw
your attention here that castle has been
tried even in the recent years and 31
games has been played from this so it's
a great possibility that you might get
in your game as well let's see what's
wrong with the MU Castle well after that
the natural move ePHI gives black a huge
difficult time I got this position
against a candidate master where my
opponent continued with the moon knight
- eh I responded with the move he
captures d6 he captured back with the
bishop and now the obvious move Knight
to B Phi so I'm trying to put as much as
pressure on the d6 square and accurate
enough my opponent tried to unpin his
Bishop with the move Queen to e7 so so
far every moon looks very logical well
here initiative started with the move
Bishop to g5 attacking the Queen and
after the move f6 Bishop to e3 and White
has created the first friend that is why
it wants to capture this bishop and
after Knight captures d6 he wants to
play Bishop to c5 and nabbing the whole
piece so something black has to respond
immediately and in the game he responded
with the
bishop to be hated okay rook a to c1 and
now the MU which black wants to play
here is a six is not possible the simple
reason is after Bishop to c5 white get
an exchange and in fact the winning edge
so accordingly two moves has been tried
from this position the first move b6 is
not good at all the simple reason is
after Bishop to b3 attacking denied
Bishop to b7 defending and now White has
this little move boom so sacrificing the
whole Bishop and black should take it
because after Bishop to c5 black is
going to lose in exchange so after a
captures b6 here comes the whole point
and this has happened in few games where
white continue with the move Bishop
check rook to f7 and now rook to d7 and
black has to surrender the Queen
otherwise his King is going to be
checkmated one game in database continue
here with Quinn to f8 but after rook f7
Queen to b4 and now the star mu look to
see for Queen to a5 which allow white to
execute the finishing nod after rook f6
a discovered check King to h8 and rook
to f8 is actually a checkmate the
highest played move in this position is
king to h8 so avoiding any sort of
problem but white still contains some
nasty tricks to illustrate my point i
like to show you a game where both the
players are in excess of 2200 rating and
here white continue with the move Bishop
to b3 so his idea is once again very
simple Bishop to c5 nabbing the exchange
so black played the obvious move quint
web 7 okay white continue with the move
Knight F to d4
so white is now pressurizing the e6
square and maybe a nightline come to
their file with some devastation
so black decided to challenge
one of the centralized night with the
moon Asics but I think this is just
asking for it before I move on I like
you to pause this video and find out
what is wrong with this initial move a6
well I hope you do calculate it long and
find out this accurate move that is
night capture c6 here black has to be
careful as he cannot take the b9 because
after a captures B Phi and the Moon
Knight captures b8 fight obtain a piece
after rook to d8 and the funny enough is
that eh Knight is not going anywhere so
accordingly in the game black played the
move B capture c6 but that allows night
to d4 attacking c6 which cannot be
defended
so black continue with the Moon Knight
to c7
but after following sequence that is
rook captures a 6:28 roped D to C one
attacking two times on the night black
get one counter with the movie Phi but
after Knight to f3 Queen to d7 and the
moon Quinn to C for black lost the piece
and in fact the game
last but not least what happens if you
open and continue with the movie six
well here why should continue with the
move Queen to e2 and now we are going to
see one of the main and the most popular
line from the black where black time
being a word the development of his g9
with the move Bishop to e7 and after
rook to d1 continue with the move Queen
to c7 here Y should continue with the
move Bishop to f4 pressurizing the d6
Square and accordingly black has to play
some accurate moves Knight to f6 is one
of the men were in this position and
against it I have shown a sample line
which is available in the PG n where by
force wide get an endgame with a slight
advantage and at least in those lies
white has draw in his hand but in the
majority of the cases black has tried
the movie Phi or Knight to e5 which
creates instant disaster for the black
for example moves such as 'if I'll
create a hole on the d5 square and white
can jump on it immediately with Knight
to d5
attacking the Queen Queen to d8 and now
the formula trick happen so many times
as white continue with Bishop to e3 and
naturally here blackest pawn with the
move Knight to f6 which is an outright
mistake as after Bishop to b6 Queen to
d7 and night to c7 black loses the
exchange with a disgusting position
the second more night to Aoife is one of
the most popular choice by the black as
if you check it out you can see over
here that Knight to e4 has been tried 57
times so what's wrong with this nature
looking move Knight to e5 well here
comes one of the most stunning trick in
the Mora gambit which is after Knight to
e5 black will continue with the move
Bishop captures ePHI pawn captures efile
and rope to save one so once again but
has set a x-ray on the Queen and all the
time in this position black has moved
the Queen either to be 8 or a 5 which
leads to some devastating tricks for the
white now it doesn't matter whether your
opponent plays Queen to e5 Queen to b8
let's say the most popular choice over
here is going to be 8 and after this can
you identify one move which instantly
gives white a great advantage okay I
hope you find this wonderful blow Pam
ahaha so white is sacrificing the whole
piece and if blacking goes to their fate
then Knight to e4 is a very strong reply
so the critical line is what happens if
you open and take this bishop
well after that obviously white is going
to continue with Knight catches B file
looking at the c7 square and kindly note
moves such as root 2 e 2 is not possible
at all because after Queen to c4 White
is immediately winning so the correct
continuation over here is King to f8
avoiding the folk anyways white we
continue with Knight to c7 attacking the
rook and rook has to move if rook to Fr
then B 4 is a very strong reply and that
rook has to move again as Bishop cannot
take the B for porn because he has to
safeguard the d8 square so accordingly
the most pop
Joy's over here is route captures a -
and it seems like black has escaped from
the worst but believe it or not this is
exactly white once and after White's
next reply Quinn to be Phi no matter
however black plays the game will be
finished very quickly so white is
threatening nothing but a checkmate and
accordingly two moves has been tried the
first move g6 is not good at all because
after the following sequence that is
Quinn check King to g7 Knight captures
ePHI attacking on f7 so black response
is force black has to continue with
night 2 at 6:00 but then comes a very
simple reply Quinn captures a 7 and the
next move Knight to e8 is going to
happen which cannot be prevented and see
the pitiable position for the black his
species can hardly move
finally the only reply left is what
happens if you open place a knight to f6
well after that the task is again very
easy white will continue with the move
Queen captures ePHI so white has a
threat now of Knight captures c6 and
nabbing the Queen so accordingly black
has to move the Queen if King to g8 then
Knight to d5 is a very strong reply so
white has the multiple threats which
cannot be prevented so let's consider
what happens if the most accurate reply
Queen to e7 has been played well against
this
my recommendation is white should
continue with the move Knight to d5 so
there is a threat of rook capture c8 so
Bishop to d7 is force but now comes the
winning blow Knight captures a 7 and not
only white get his piece back but a
tremendous attack to vote
the problem here is black cannot take
this Nile because of the following
reason
if King takes c7 then after the
following continuation that is Queen
check King to e8 rook to c7 so three pcs
are eyeing at the d7 square so the only
way to defend is to play Queen to e4 but
then white has this lethal blow rope to
c1 and in fact that is no stopping on
the CA except black has to give up the
Queen and get tortured by white for a
long time well I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful tricks in the Smith
Morra gambit accepted male-line thank
you for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care